المزيد همم معنا ليلى عوده مراسلات فرانس
24 في القدس اهلا بك الليله راينا في
السياق وتفاصيل وملابسات عمليه الطعندهم
ودهس تم تنفيذهما بحسب حتى الان المصادر
الاسرائيليه سواء من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي
او على المستوى السياسي فان فلسطينيه همم
تمكن من الوصول الى مدخل مستوطنه اريل قرب
سلفيت وهي المستوطنه المقاومه على اراضي
سلفيت قربنا نابلس داخل المستوطنه وصل الى
محطه الوقود داخل هذه المستوطنه وبدات
بعمليه الطعن همم في داخل محطه الوقود ادت
الى اصابه اسرائيل
بعضها استقل السيارات الموجوده داخل محطه
الوقود
وتوجهها عكس اتجاه السير الى شارع خمسه
بدا بعمليه دهس لسيارات اسرائيليين ادت
الى اصابه ايضا همم اثنين اخرين اصابتهما
خطيره بعد ذلك تم الاعلان عن مقتل ثلاثه
من الجرحى وجود عدد اخر من الاصابات من
بينها نزلت هناك اصابه او اثنتين نا في
حاله الخطر وفي طبيعه الحال هناك اجراءات
امنيه مشدده في عين المكان لازالت اغلاق
الطريق
وتنزل شكرا لك ليلى عوده شكرا لك مراسله
فرانس 24 في القدس على كل هذه التفا